da kommen wird viel gemeckert sehen wir
mal das positive die gefährlichen euro 5
diele die dürfen bald nicht mehr in die
innenstädte nur noch die blitzsauberen
euro sechs modelle und die benziner ich
meine die machen eh' kein dreck wirklich
wir schalten darüber zu ulrich von
heesen in die heute-show kfz-werkstatt
ulrich können wir jetzt alle aufatmen
die labortests der autoindustrie hat er
vergessen
ich mache hier meine eigene dieser euro
6 diesel hier müller schon seit stunden
wurde hier und jetzt gäste in
verschiedene sachen wie reagieren
zimmerpflanzen wie reagieren haustiere
keine angstgegner der beta des lebens
nur und natürlich alles andere wäre
unseriös testen wir das auch an senioren
wobei wir hier gerade auf dem schweizer
fehlt der typ hier ist erst anfang 30
und jetzt kommt der hammer welt wird
tolle neue euro 6 lüftet doppelte wie
stickoxid auf die laster oder busse
ehrlich aber wieso darf er dann weiter
in die innenstadt fahren weil der euro 6
wieso das ist eins mehr als 5
hätte man das spiel die problem wenn
dieses von links lösen können mit
besseren catalis dazu an
aber dokument und die autoindustrie hat
eine viel über 3d software updates für
60 euro haben die zeitschrift auto motor
und sport hat die abgabe eines vw amarok
gemessen
das ergebnis die stickoxidwerte sind
nach dem update für hoch wie zuvor von
400 prozent über dem grenzwert
okay zugegeben er macht nach dem update
genau so viel wie vorher aber hat einen
neuen hochtouren
okay vergessen wir den wiesel was es mit
modernen ventil an umfragen die sind
nämlich riechen schreibe etwas weniger
stickoxid dafür die ganze feinstaub
welche machen wir uns nichts vor autos
wild schmutz immer über sexismus muss
ich sagen sonst macht kein spaß
saubere autos das ist wie leckeres
veganes essen das liebt es mit ein
mythos
ja aber es muss doch was passieren dann
müssen wir halt machen wie in oslo
da fliegen die autos bei ganz aus der
innenstadt ja genau so machen würde
in ihrer rosaroten helau für die welt
das hier ist deutschland eine stolze ps
nation zweites von mir weniger art 2
bestellen sie noch heute die von mir die
seite
archiv ein schock als echte wohltat die
atemluft und liest geil aus
oder geht so unrecht meine damen und
herren
[Applaus]